donc bonjour à tous comme vous voulez le
voir aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous parler
d'art mais je pense que mon style est
important que je vous explique un peu ce
qui m'arrive est en fait à réfléchir sur
la donc je vous écris un peu le contexte
j'étais chez moi j'étais seul et pour
une raison quelconque j'étais
terriblement en colère à ce moment là
j'étais ce talent et beaucoup j'avais un
vrai besoin de pouvoir exprimer sa
colère pouvoir l'extérioriser est la
seule et unique victime potentielle à la
disposition et c'est une pauvre feuille
blanche qui est déposé sur le lourd j'ai
décidé donc de man saisir et j'ai
exprimé toute ma rage toute la colère
que je pouvais ressentir à ce moment là
donc je vous l'accordé ce culte un
massacre cet été les les mais c'est là
me fait beaucoup de bien et je vous
retourne et mclane les occupations et
faire autre chose mais un peu plus tard
dans la journée je revenais vers les
plus hauts je revis la feuille et je
l'observais un moment je dépense il est
sans savoir pourquoi un doute petites
annonces et s'empara de bras un doute
qui privait faisant plus d'importance
jusqu'à devenir assez insupportable sans
savoir pourquoi je me répétais et si
juste voir la volonté que j'avais eu de
pouvoir extérioriser exprimer ma colère
et si j'allais produits dollars mais
comment en être sûr
comment le savoir car finalement
qu'est-ce que l'art
je ne savais absolument pas ce que
c'était et le fallait réponse une
réponse fiable et réponses solides et
comme toute personne à la recherche de
réponses fiables et solides
je fais appel à mon meilleur ami
wikipedia et multimédia la pipe mot pour
mot l'art est une activité humaine
le produit de cette activité l'idée
en fait s'adressant délibérément au sens
aux émotions aux intuitions et à la télé
j'avoue qu'après une telle réponse
critique et n était plus beaucoup mon
ami et que j'ai décidé d'aller chercher
ma réponse elle est alors je décide donc
d'aller rencontrer des personnes qui
avant moi c'était elle aussi intéressé à
l'art intéressé à sa définition
je remontais loupé siècle et je
rencontrais flat en effet at on appris
que là nous éloigner du bo alors je vais
parfaitement d'accord avec lui là nous
éloigne du bon lait cependant le bo est
un concept aussi un peu trop subjectif à
mon goût par exemple bon plateau
le bo est la vérité et la rue témoigne
du bocal avec une représentation fausse
et du monde qui nous entoure
je cherchais donc une autre définition
qui me convient le mieux j'avançais dans
le temps et je rencontre et quand
et quand tu me dis là est loch original
est inné du génie guidés par la nature
je vous avoue lui j'étais extrêmement
flatté par cette définition mais encore
une fois le père de jeanne imaginer car
il signifie que seule une minorité de
personnes pouvaient être considérés
comme de vrais artistes
non je m'étais toujours pas d'accord il
nous fallait encore autre chose
j'avance là encore un peu dans le temps
et je m'en confesse cette fois-ci
nietzsche qui avec son optimisme
habituel n'a pris que la vie était
parfaitement dénué de sens merci dit 'je
suis toujours plaisir voilà études
doivent essayer désespérément de donner
du sens à la ville par la parole par les
idées et pas rares cependant mon oeil je
pense que nous en convainc green avait
pas vraiment de sens
ou alors elle en a bien certainement
tout moi et pour vous qui connaissez un
peu le contexte
sa création est un grand nombre
d'oeuvres d'art malgré cela pouvait
penser certains spécialistes donc pas
vraiment de sens il y en a il faut
arrêter pour chercher s'il vous plaît et
non pas de sens
d'accord bon alors si elle devait en la
barre il s'est certainement différent
pour chaque personne qui ferait face à
cette oeuvre d'art donc encore une fois
la définition ne me convenait pas cette
fois ci il fallait que je rencontre
encore quelqu'un que j'ai une nouvelle
définition est plutôt que de m'adresser
à des philosophes qui allait réfléchir
sur la distance pour qu elle va
rencontrer quelqu'un qui pratiquer l'art
quotidiennement je rencontre est donc un
par le peintre google qui me dit non
pour mollahs avec une attraction
c'est le moyen de monteverdi en faisant
que notre divin maître crée alors
j'étais plutôt d'accord sur le fait que
l'arrêté sur l'abstraction
cependant lorsque je l'avais prouvé
qu'elle avait absolument pas envie de
monter leur dieu je suis très bien
entraîné et je me dit plus que nous
allons comme beaucoup de choses que dieu
serait temps meilleurs créateurs que moi
car ils ont pu sinon nous aurions été
assez peu fonctionnel en gare
saint-charles
voilà donc j'avais l'ubs ont rencontré
des philosophes gelé pour rencontrer
tous les types etienne c'était pourtant
la source la plus fiable
j'avais rencontré peintre et pourtant
j'étais vaut mieux qu'un départ qu'ils
avaient toujours pas cet été là est la
question persiste et qu'est ce que la
caisse car il me fallait que j'y pense à
tout prix dans l'ue tout était
réellement insupportable et je me dis
tout simplement pourquoi ne pourrais-je
pas proposer ma propre définition de
l'art et des finitions qui causerait
davantage à l'idée personnelle est assez
subjectif je peux me faire
dollar et cette définition la voici
l'art est une intention de créer et
uniquement une intention de créer mais
attention dans cette définition le mot
créé est important et d'équité de
production produire un objet du minima
que l'unité pourquoi pas mais ce qui est
vraiment important dans cette définition
c'est le mot intentions par exemple si
on prend un ouvrier qui produira à la
chaîne dans une usine des objets mais
dans le simple plus de pouvoir subvenir
à ses besoins matériels
c'est un à produire et quelque chose
mais ne sait par l'artiste mais c'est
vraiment petit coup lieu c'est même
isolé dans cette même entreprise cette
même usine
le timétrine et la passion dans ce qu'il
ferait s'il considère l objet créé comme
une fin plus que comme un moyen qui lui
servirait à subvenir à ses besoins et à
l'aîné un coup d'argent lui devait être
considérée comme l'artiste est réglé une
réelle intention une réelle passion dans
sa production
cependant je ne peux pas me permettre
simplement de vous imposer cette
proposition cette nouvelle définition
comme toute définition philosophique
celle ci se doit d'être démontrée et
quoi de plus efficace de plus beau de
plus rappelé lorsqu'on cherche à
démontrer quelque chose que les
mathématiques
oui c'est la petite phrase ition et du
cou cependant depuis le début du plus
dans une des philosophies de l'art et
j'ai maintenant essayer de passer à une
démonstration mathématique donc il faut
que j'arrive à faire le lien entre les
fileuses
et les mathématiques est ce bien le
voici c'est une proposition sur lesquels
va se baser plus ou moins le veste de
moto je vais considérer que le concept
philosophique s'apparente à un ensemble
mathématiques et j'ai tout de suite vous
expliquer le plus clairement possible
pourquoi un ensemble la thématique est
simplement une collection d'objets voyez
le coin comme un grand 7 contiendrait un
nombre donné d'objets et le concept d'un
objet en philosophie et simplement le
vide et qui va se faire l'esprit humain
d'un objet et du coup cette idée nous
allons vous faire d'un objet repose sur
l'ensemble des objets similaires que
nous avons déjà rencontré par le passé
ça peut paraître un peu confus comme ça
donc je laissais prends l'exemple le
plus concret prenons le concept du stylo
donc le concept de l'objet stylo
concernait en fait tous les objets nommé
stylo que vous avez rencontrés jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et quand vous rencontrerez
un nouvel objet dans la vie tous les
jours vous prenez cet objet vous le
comparez à l'ensemble des objets qui
composent votre concept stylo et vous
concluez oui non cet objet est il un
stylo ne l'est-il pas j'espère que c'est
un peu plus que la cobra à présent le
lien entre le constate et l'ensemble est
géré en tout les portes
attention ce n'est pas de notation
mathématiques c'est justement à qui
l'introduit pouvoir simplifier un mot
les écritures quand je vous parlerai
d'un concept je vais fait entre
parenthèses donc rappelé luc bien je
l'utilisé par la suite dans la
démonstration
voilà pour nous pouvons revenir à la
composition qui nous intéresse
la définition que nous allons tenter de
démontrer aujourd'hui la est une
intention de créer très rapidement on se
rencontre que cette définition implique
quelque chose de très important
césar est une intention buffet cela
implique nécessairement que n'importe
l'objet doit pouvoir appartenir au
concept d'art c'est assez logique
on est donc en droit de se demander est
ce vrai que n'importe quel objet puisse
appartenir au concept d'art ou plutôt
posons nous la question qu'est ce que le
concept d'art soyons capables de définir
un ensemble pour le concept d'art qui
contiendrait un nombre donné d'objets
car après tout quand on y pense
l'art est différent selon les pays là
est différent selon les époques
l'art est différent selon le contexte
social politique économique
en vérité l'arrêté différents l'art est
différent l'art sera différent et par
conséquent on aura beau essayer
il sera complètement impossible de
définir et délimiter ce qu'est le
concept bar sans vrai expliqué
simplement canton de délimiter le
concept d'art au jour 0 il suffit qu
entre le jour 0 et 20 jours un un
artiste un peu un ingénieur un peu
origin a créé quelque chose qui
s'appelle rare et qui renouvelle un peu
la définition qu'on pouvait avoir cet
objet là ça se fait dans le concept
d'arval agrandir et par conséquent le
concept d'air sera plus grand aux
joueurs qu'ils ne l'étaient au jour 0 de
la même manière entre le jour 1a et le
jour 2 de la même manière entre le
joueur est née la semaine +1 et par
conséquent on aura beau essayer le
concept d' avec un concept qui peut
contenir toujours plus d'objets et une
telle diversité objets qu'on avait assez
rapidement à la conclusion que le
concept
faites un concept qu'il contient et il
peut potentiellement contenir une
infinité d'objets est à ce point là on
est assez content car un concept qui
contient une infinité d'objets peut
contenir n'importe quel objet et puisque
ce concept qui contient n'importe quel
objet et le concept d'art c'est que
n'importe quel objet peut appartenir au
concept d'art aller vers ce point je
vous laisse quelques instants pour vous
remettre du choc émotionnel
vous pouvez pleurer de joie
vous pouvez considérer plutôt existence
s'il vous plaît n'allait pas s'il en est
tout simplement je suis désolé de vous
décevoir mais ce que nous venons de
prouver ici est en fait absolument pas
ce que nous voulions prouver au départ
c'est à dire ma définition là est une
intention de créer car regardez bien le
sens de l'implication il est très
important en mathématiques
sylla et jim l'intention de clés cela
implique nécessairement que n'importe
quel objet doit pouvoir appartenir à
l'art mais avec ce sens d'implication il
est absolument pas suffisant que
n'importe quel objet puisse appartenir
au lard pour plus la retraite une
intention de créer autrement dit nous
venons de prouver quelque chose qui
n'était pas assez précis nous venons de
prouver que n'importe quel objet peut
appartenir dollar mais c'est que je
voulais prouver au départ et que
n'importe quel objet produit avec une
intention de créer puis appartenir à
dollars donc arriver à ce stade là nous
avons démontré quelque chose de très
intéressant
n'importe quel objet peut avoir comme
iras dollar est cependant nous n'avons
toujours pas réussi à prouver ma
définition là est une intention de créer
mais après tout il faut que je vous
avoue quelque chose dès le début je vous
ai menti je suis désolé mon but était
pas vraiment imposée tyranniquement de
démontrer qu'ils
par la force des mathématiques cette
définition l'art est une intention de
créer mon but était plutôt de pouvoir
vous la proposer d'avoir un public qui
serait prêt à l'écouter qui serait prêt
à en discuter avec moi car en vérité en
philosophie le but n'est jamais de
trouver une réponse unique à une
question donnée
le but est tout simplement de prendre un
concept d'en discuter de le faire
évoluer et par conséquent peu importe si
nous avons réussi à obtenir un résultat
unique à la fin le concept a évolué nous
avons participé aujourd'hui à évoluer la
définition de là et c'est déjà beaucoup
voyez vous aujourd'hui à notre échelle
nous avons été un petit peu philosophe
par conséquent au journal officiel nous
avons été un petit peu mathématicien à
notre petite idée
aujourd'hui nous avons tous ensemble eu
la volonté de toi créer ces moments ce
moment des changes et par poser quand
aujourd'hui à notre échelle nous avons
été un peu d artistes
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]